la pesca se convirtió en un punto de
honor en las negociaciones del price y
este es uno de los tres temas que
dificultan un acuerdo comercial entre la
unión europea y reino unido- ahora que
los británicos están a tres semanas de
salirse del mercado como un europeo
y luego también está el tema de la pesca
donde todavía tenemos un largo camino
por recorrer pero ya sabes la esperanza
es eterna y hace todo lo posible para
solucionarlo si podemos que surjan son
una de las grandes discusiones es qué
pasará con los pesqueros europeos en el
mar del norte mientras bruselas propuso
ceder a londres un 18 por ciento de su
cuota pesquera reino unido quiere
gobernar sus aguas por primera vez en 40
años y decidir quién entra y quién sale
además propone negociar anualmente cómo
funcionará la pesca esto preocupa a
países como francia o dinamarca pues una
buena parte de su pesca se hace en aguas
británicas y auxiliares aunque no hay
razón para dejar que todo se vaya solo
porque es importante para los británicos
y digamos te dejaremos bloquear nuestro
acceso a tus aguas eso es inaceptable
simple
el secretario ya había advertido que
francia está dispuesta a oponerse a un
eventual acuerdo si éste no garantiza
condiciones comerciales equitativas para
sus pescadores el tema es tan álgido
para los franceses que incluso el primer
ministro jan castex se reunió con
sindicatos pesqueros la semana anterior
si los británicos restringen los barcos
europeos cerca de 180 mil personas
perderían su trabajo pero la unión
europea presiona a londres diciéndole
que si quiere un comercio sin aranceles
deberá garantizar el acceso a sus aguas